what are your thoughts about kids and
screens the issue is not screens the
issue is hypocrisy you can't talk about
screens all day and say how shitty they
are and then when you have your friend
over and the kids are making noise you
throw the iPad at them I just don't
understand why parents continue to blame
technology instead of themselves and the
second you blame yourself well then you
can start controlling the outcome you
want
we are getting better and better and
better and better at pointing fingers
it's the government's fault it's this
religion's fault it's this Tech
company's fault it's this app's fault
it's this influencer's fault we've
gotten so good
at blaming absolutely everything but
ourselves that we're starting to hit a
Tipping Point the reason people are so
unhappy is because they're judging
everyone we're all judging each other
which is actually just a tell that means
you're judging yourself
we're just in this Perpetual thing and
so
you know I think screens are incredibly
positive and Incredibly negative the
same way I feel about everything
start the beginning of a new
Society I think it's time to start
blaming ourselves
and the second you blame yourself well
then you can start controlling the
outcome you want but blaming screens but
then not enforcing it in your own home
when you have 100 control because you're
worried about your child being mad at
you for a little while
seemed soft
what world do you think your children
are going to be living in screens are
going to be Amateur hour
if the metaverse is Right which I think
it's very hard to see a world of why it
would not be right because I would argue
we live in the metaverse now how many
hours are you spending looking at a
screen
so you know like where do you think this
is going I would be flabbergasted if in
60 years people aren't living in a Ready
Player One World it would make no sense
to me other than vacationing out of it
but like
technology only goes in One Direction
We're not gonna ride horses down the
highway it's not happening
just a quick question about our kids 90
of what the kids are learning at school
is gonna be done by a high much in a
much easier you're very nice okay 99 so
my question is how can we direct them
into things that you think AI is not
because for me the future is going to be
Ai and human doing things together so
what part on The Human Side can we push
our kids giving someone advice on how to
parent their child is the worst one on
one macro there's clearly themes couple
things right now schools across the
world are Banning
chat GPT
what can we do we can push against the
schools and have a meaningful
conversation here's what I mean by that
schools are Banning chat GPT because
they don't understand it they're banning
it because they think it's cheating or
it's undermining what they're selling
they're selling memorization of
commodity of information
schools are selling
for our children to memorize
information that is commodity because
it's at the fingertips of our phones
meanwhile chat GPT and AI is about to
teach the world the value of critical
thinking
chat GPT sucks
if you don't input
thoughtful critical thinking so we have
this moment in time right now
where we can literally teach children
how to critically think the singular
thing that actually matters when we get
older
yet we're just watching and as a matter
of fact most parents are cheering the
Banning of Chach EBT because they fear
new things they're lazy to look into it
or they're just not thoughtful enough to
realize what the [__] is going on so I
think a couple things one it's gonna be
hard for you to find all the parents in
the school to convince the school not
that that's going to be hard but what
you do at home is not hard and it's no
different than screens if a child feels
from a parent when the school is saying
no to something that they come home and
you're saying yes to it and you're
teaching them while you're learning
Yourself by the way of how to use these
tools it's invigorating because most
kids start off not fully wanting to
conform and then they're just beating
down into it and then they become
anxious because they want to conform to
doing well on something every 90 days
and the whole thing is just whack so I
think the biggest thing you can do is
try to teach them how to critically
think and I think AI is the first
scalable tool I mean you could have done
it with search but we that was you know
we almost became too commoditized and we
don't think of it that way but there's a
lot of actual critical thinking in
search like the better you are at it the
better your results will be however AI
makes Google feel like the encyclopedia
when this is all said and done we'll all
be telling our grandchildren no it
Google was amazing that's why we did
everything and they're gonna laugh
the same way that we all laugh at the
Yellow Pages today so I think doing
things with your children whether it's
hiking playing video games like anything
you can do with your child forms a real
relationship it's just very powerful
normally we've already done the things
we do with our children but if you're
able to go with your child on this
journey together on how to become a
critical thinker as an inputer to
artificial intelligence and maybe one of
the most fruitful Journeys you can go on
thank you very much cheers
[Music]